[Music]
those are big dinosaurs
[Music]
hey i am d bradley baker i'm a voice
actor who's known for doing creatures
monsters
and animal sounds in a lot of hollywood
projects
[Applause]
my first break probably in voice acting
would be a nickelodeon game show called
legends of the hidden temple legends of
the hidden temple with your guide kirk
fogg
i got to do lots of different voices as
this big rock god olmec i moved his
mouth and spoke it's my temple that was
kind of my first gig where it became
clear to me that i think i want to do
something like this
um how about uh some birds well let's
see turkey
[Music]
when i close off my nose it gives a
resonance to it that makes it feel
bigger
for instance
like that or
it's almost like closing off valves on a
wind instrument is how i think of it all
right we can wrap it up
i work on all kinds of different fun
shows some of my notable characters
might be klaus on american dad hello
francine i'm ready for my fish feeding
now i was daffy duck in space jam all
right bub
let's make fun of the duck harry the
platypus in phineas and ferb
a lot of characters in spongebob
squillium fancy son and perch perkins
action news and maybe a cop fish there's
a fly
[Music]
[Applause]
help me
i'll get you my pretty where was it
it's a dead fly
see if there's anybody else that's alive
in here now i'm really into taking
pictures of bugs and small critters it's
a little ant line i think it's eating
like aphids off there bugs are like
alien robots they're just they're
amazing and they have such power and
such intelligence and such beauty in
their design and all of these things i
find useful to have within me for when
i'm creating
vocal creations here look at that
ant isn't that beautiful
[Music]
watching biology documentaries
the nature series planet earth series i
mean those give me all kinds of specific
ideas in terms of sounds
okay ready ten-year-old d would be
impressed that middle hd is doing
creatures and monster sounds because i
loved animals and creatures and it
looked like a lot of fun
i want to put things out into the world
that make the world better and show how
interesting and good it is
[Music]
you